to get to that level well that's why
when you see a real high level wrestler
against almost everybody else they have
such a noted advantage in the clinch
like Daniel Cormier and Stevie Miocic
this weekend yeah what I mean Dominick
Cruz such a we're very fortunate to have
a guy that knowledgeable in in because
Dominic's knowledgeable about basically
everything he started out as a wrestler
but he understands MMA as good as
anybody that's ever talked on the mic
about MMA he's very clued up so when he
talked about like he showed me some
stuff that I hadn't caught about
Daniel's giving up the the underhook so
that he could limp arm and then steep a
would run right into the right hand they
had it all timed out
yeah I really broke another file I was
just already lazy I was yelling off my
face it's like wow dude when he
connected and then he hit him I don't
even know if I said anything cuz I
remember I was going like I thought I'd
be five rounds fire
there was a deja vu moment so close
beautiful picture mates they've been
working together for so long when John
annek stands up any look at that picture
because who the [ __ ] else is a two-time
world champion in two divisions and also
a commentator currently and a great
working two jobs god I love that guy man
more like these chunky as well yes he
just like Chucky's a nice way of putting
it no I was a girl champion his
nutrition he says like 246 but he
doesn't move like 240 seconds I yeah
hundred percent so it's deceptive yeah
you look at him like even Marcone he's
another guy like that put last Saturday
the way he was moving well I was talking
about it in Kampen and so was Bob Cook
they were telling me after the fight
they go dude
and heavyweight he's knocking everybody
out in training part it's almost forgot
about Strikeforce how about that
undefeated Strikeforce [ __ ] Grand
Prix Heavyweight Champion tossing upper
net Bigfoot dropping him all that kind
of [ __ ] I was right and that was brought
up with five rounds and he wasn't even
like he was early and I was early in his
MMA career yeah so I was like
you guys are in a sense oh I thought was
gonna be DC putting them against the
fence
grinding them out for five rounds and
still beating them up for like I'm
[ __ ] them all and back and forth but
knockout in the first round that was
just crazy
yeah crazy I thought it started DC was
gonna win it what was gonna happen was
they were gonna get into the second and
third and they were gonna start getting
tired and DC's wrestling was gonna take
over yeah I was a five-round yeah mr. DC
but I felt like he had to somehow or
another where ste pay out a little bit
before he gets takedowns yeah it's the
face I thought that would be the smart
thing to do but I thought it was real
dangerous standing up because steep a is
knocked out Junior dos Santos is longer
Alistair Overeem knocked out for Bri
silver doom with one punch
I mean you think all the people steep a
is knocked out to go damn and DC's
coming up as a light heavyweight
yeah well in DC hurt was a rumble right
yeah Jones obviously forget that
capitalize brilliantly on a tendency you
know he knew that DC departing yeah
leaning mm-hmm what's interesting is
that Dominick Cruz explained this to me
as well is that this is how DC prefers
to set up the single and that he prefers
to leave it on that side lean in towards
his right side and then dive in on the
single that's his preferred technique
it's very strong and dragging you to the
ground from that position mmm tendency
everyone does every Levin